yes
eric fleet the stream is starting soon
hopefully it already started
uh so let me just check if people are
here
yes they are uh all right so hello
everyone
and welcome to the agar matra birthday
arena my birthday was
some three days ago on the 16th of june
so we're having this
uh uh well i thought it would be a nice
idea to organize
uh a tournament problem is i organized
it at the exact same time
as the leaches titled arena which i only
learned today but
uh what are you going to do you live and
you learn
uh but uh i i don't think it's gonna
take away anything from the title arenas
that's only for title players and here
pretty much
everyone can uh can take part uh so yeah
uh who do we who do we have uh first in
the chat like we
said eric fleet martin cork kevin wag
aiden wang nick who loves me so much
thank you nick gautam gopai
omegacroc 29 tom sheldon luba uh hello
hello everyone
uh so yeah uh the tournament starts in
16 minutes uh it's a
two-hour tournament and it's two minutes
per player without any increment i
thought
i thought maybe one minute would be uh
too much uh as it
you know not everyone is into bullet i
know it's pretty crazy
why why wouldn't everyone be in the
bullet but most people are actually in
the blitz
so i thought two minutes would be a nice
uh
well a nice mix up sort of a goldilocks
time format not
not too fast not too slow maybe
maybe uh two minutes would be just right
uh so yeah uh i think there should be a
link in the description below like first
thing you should
you see should be a link to the
tournament so if you still haven't
joined
uh do join there are two or two thousand
seven hundred and eighty players so far
and people are still joining in so
uh you might not win first place but uh
you know that's
if that was the criteria for joining
tournaments uh a few people would
would actually join uh yes uh
uh abcdefg says it will
it's all in the description boys
am i sad croatia couldn't win yesterday
no not not really if you're referring to
football
i did watch the game uh but uh
no i i'm not sad uh it'd be great for
the economy of course if we if we
qualified for the
you know upper parts of the of the
competition but uh you
you never know
i have the same birthday as psy okay
uh yeah uh how old am i uh 34 i am 34.
i i do not know what a cookie clicker is
but yeah 14 minutes until uh until the
arena starts so
if you guys want we can we can play a
game or two uh until that
time arrives like maybe maybe a one
maybe a bullet game or or maybe a two
minute game
yeah uh two hours uh everything says in
the description it's a two-hour bullet
arena
so everyone plays against everyone and
you know to infinity berserking is of
course allowed
i do not like tournaments where
berserking is not allowed uh and
uh aside from my one thousand dollars
price
fund uh a lot of people contributed so
uh there is now
almost uh twelve hundred dollars price
fund so uh prices have increased a
little bit
if any of you are interested you're
welcome to increase it further
but i will only include that in the in
the prices after the stream
since i have to do some uh photoshopping
action to to do that
who's my favorite football player uh
i'm pretty sure i don't have one uh i've
watched some football not a lot you know
maybe a a long long time ago
yes vodka and chess takes away the
stress but a favorite football player i
i don't know if i could pick one
what are what are some good football
players uh you joined the arena
just by clicking on the first link in
the description below and then you click
uh join ronaldinho
chronoldino is here
is it worth playing it on a phone yeah
i mean it it's two minutes you you
definitely can play it on the phone
all right okay we have a nice casual
nice casual bullet game by
let me just check or or or or by
submit
yeah okay there's still time to join so
maybe maybe we even hit
3 000 players all right so let's play
against
this uh scandinavian
it's not a not a very good one or even
appears to be a scandinavian but it's a
bullet so we'll we'll do our best
all right let's just see what happens
all right let's uh do well
time wise all right let's do this this
this and then this
all right he's he's coming at me that's
always
very nice yeah this is
happening definitely let's push he's
gonna push as well
uh but we we need to be faster than him
all right so we're gonna capture this
simply because we can and then
okay nice
nice nice now we're now we're winning
but we have to we still have to win
um yeah let's uh let's let's capture
here play this
we actually don't mind that let's push
uh let's push even further i guess
and now let's get this guy here captures
captures and
ca this check is kind of nice
um yeah let's uh let's do this
try and eliminate this guy he doesn't
have a dark square bishop so we don't
have to worry about
that i guess let's do this with a nice
double attack
and he's better on time but uh
it's fine let's capture this guy
uh let's oh i almost blundered uh
i almost blundered here so it's a good
thing i didn't
all right let's attack his rook here
capture the knight
alright and should be okay so he's not
interested in that
okay nice okay thank you thank you for
that
very nice uh very nice win i did not
deserve it i played terrible but what
are you gonna do
uh that's that's how bullet works all
right ten more minutes so we
we we have time for uh for a few more
all right
excellation
no no my daughter is not uh still in the
hospital she actually arrived some
some week ago yeah exactly a week ago
all right let's go for a nice king's
gambit
uh and see what happens
usually good good things will happen
all right let's do okay he's uh
he's uh spending a lot of time here
which is never a good idea and bullet
yeah what are you going to do all right
so he he gives up another pawn
which is always nice
let's go oh yeah let's let's not go back
let's play play this
all right thank you for that
let's castle in d4 no not even d4
yeah let's let's let's play like this
e5 let's pick up this guy
uh oh he's he's actually faster than me
is it uh because my
internet is slow or am i just or am i
just slow
yeah he oh now he has a lot of nasty
discoveries i miss this
i missed this ah the horror
the horror let's do a nice check
here e6 maybe and now
what is this what is this
this is not what i signed up for this is
a free bishop
oh this is pretty crazy yeah let's block
this
and even this may be new
okay so we definitely don't wanna
let's do it like this okay wow
nice okay
thank you for that very nicely done
let's go here avoid the checks
nice nice nice that's what we enjoy
let's go here
all right that was that was very sneaky
that was very sneaky
3 000 people have joined all right 3 000
people officially joined the tournament
uh starts in seven minutes so we can
play another
another one maybe another nice bullet
game
uh you can join the tournament by
clicking on the link in the description
below
um all right here we have basilos
[Music]
uh if you send some money for the price
full now
i will only update it after the
tournament but i will list uh put a list
of everyone who contributed for the
tournament
uh in in tomorrow's video so no worries
there
all right so maybe i kind of messed up
here a little
but it's okay yeah it's maybe not
great but
will will live i guess yeah he really
wants to double my pawns but once he
doubles them
then we're gonna be fine all right let's
try and get him to take this guy as well
uh yeah that's uh that's very reasonable
i would say yeah let's grab this guy go
here and now we can yeah that's that's
pretty great that's pretty great
it's pretty great yeah let's defend this
guy get this knight here
it's a very nice night and now we could
maybe even
take this and do this
no all right fair that's fair
all right so he is doing much better
here but
that's okay that's okay uh that's fine
okay so let's take here and go here
uh we can even pick up the rook so
that's always nice
and okay it's not made but we are doing
well
we are doing well here unless we're not
unless we're not
this now falls oh this could be this
could be very ugly
oh i don't like this i don't like this
one bit
my rooks are not active and this is
pretty
pretty bad let's go here and now we
flag oh no it's made nice nice that's
that's the good stuff
he really helped me with that with that
pawn push
all right uh so five minutes left uh
3185 people all right so
uh even even increasing even further
yeah i think thanks everyone for the
for the birthday wishes um it was
actually three days ago
but uh i i couldn't stream three days
ago so i decided to shift it over
uh over for today uh which is kind of
unfortunate
uh since today is also leeches titled
arena but you know
it's always nice when things work out
but it's sometimes
they sometimes don't so there's also
that
all right priyanish yeah assassin plays
doing great man doing great all right
let's do some d4
action i'm not a d4 player but
you know uh in bullet i i could be
uh perhaps uh
i just want to play some h4h5 maybe
develop this bishop and then play king
f1 and hopefully
hopefully things work out all right
let's capture here
okay he's going for that very nice
all right so he's not interested in my
pawn i will just capture this
uh and maybe try and re-maneuver
my knight a little bit um
yeah okay so maybe now g4 and
if i can get g5 in no he's not allowing
me this
he's very he's very persistent here
which is great all right so we can't
play this we have to go like this
uh yeah we'll take that okay we'll take
this he fixes our pawn structure d5 and
now we get
this beautiful diagonal for our bishop
he wants to go here with the queen
uh which is fine not not much we can do
here
uh let's go if he captures the pawn i
will get the semi-open g file which
might be okay uh
okay he he plays it well he plays it
well
yeah i would i would do that as well
let's try and open up this
let's try and open this up and if he
moves the knight
somewhere yeah let's go here and now
we're now we're gonna try and uh
do some damage yeah let's go here
uh let's go okay that's pretty pretty
intense let's go here i have no idea
what i'm
trying to do yeah that's pretty
unfortunate
pretty unfortunate oh he had it he had i
think queen h1 was made
oh i'm super lucky here let's go here
okay i blundered a rook but he didn't
see it
let's go here let's go here
all right we're gonna have to flag him
there there's no other way
let's capture this can go here here
here all right so that was a that was a
some dirty flagging but uh there was no
other way
he simply played uh played too good
so uh i i had to resort to some dirty
flagging
uh pilate it's your birthday too uh
happy birthday man
misha is
yes when all else fails we resort to
some dirty flagging action
all right so uh it's uh uh the
tournament starts at
one hour and 35 minutes so we're gonna
as usual we're gonna check out
the games uh from the from the top of
the table
and then we're gonna you know work our
way down slowly uh where we can show
everyone
there are now three three thousand three
hundred and forty five players but we
will
uh we will try to you know uh be fair in
our choosing of the games of course uh
he who plays the evans gambit is always
showcased so uh keep that in mind
let me just check
all right a few more people have a few
more people have donated towards the
price so the price
has been increased somewhat uh i think
there's like a three donations
maybe maybe 130 dollars so
overall prices will be increased by for
now uh
that price so we actually don't know
what the price fund for this tournament
is uh for the moment it's like uh
fourteen hundred dollars
but you know could be could be more at
the end of the tournament
uh so who knows and not even the winners
will know
until i you know work it out after after
the tournament
uh i i didn't take into consideration
that people would also be
uh maybe contributing during the
tournament um
so yeah uh so so for the moment it it it
is as it is first place stands at some
834 dollars but it will be
uh will be more once i once i update it
yeah no no fourth or fifth place i i
didn't really put
that much thought into it i just uh you
know wanted to
do a nice tournament okay so what do we
have here
let's uh check out the first game so
it's uh
uh ascencio who is the top seed in the
tournament
unrated player or uh probably rated but
uh untitled against grand master zaven
chesmud and uh asensio also berserk the
grandmaster so this is gonna be this is
gonna be fun
all right
because why why wouldn't you berserk a
grandmaster of course
hey david kimura welcome man
[Music]
david the legend
all right so can can this guy ascencio
really
really do it let's see uh i'm gonna
quickly check
i doubt that he has any initials oh wow
queen captures an h2 oh
oh man look at this checkmate queen
captures on h2
nice and then after king captures bishop
f2 will be a discovered checkmate wow
that is insane
okay we're definitely keeping this game
for later
as this could be uh this could be even a
game that we we showed tomorrow
uh but this this was very impressive
okay
this was this was wow
i mean what was that who does this
i still i still do not believe what i
just what i just saw
ah you can't see names really
i really i really tried uh tried hard
to make names visible but the it's
because uh
leeches makes it the different for uh
for tournaments and also a different for
when you play
alone so unfortunately that's why
uh you can't see it but you know we're
gonna fix it no problem
let me just do a few quick uh mouse
clicks here and there all right let's
say let's say
this will do and yeah let's uh
do this one all right so
yeah pretty sure is it gonna be fine now
all right so maybe not uh maybe not
perfect but
now we know who's playing who and what
what the time is
all right so let's let's see uh
i am ready to eat against knighting
satyasai
portugal lost to germany how very how
very sad for germany
yeah i mean but what what what what was
that what a start to the tournament
this is uh uh oh i'm pretty sure
that's my next game to to show on the
channel
i i can't uh that there's no reason to
add the paypal link on the screen you
can't click on this
on i mean on the links on the screen uh
but for those uh
those of you who want to contribute to
the price fund of the tournament uh you
you are more than welcome to do it
where where am i now i'm in croatia
youtube is not receiving enough video to
maintain smooth streaming
as such viewers will experience
buffering so sorry if you guys are
experiencing buffering but
it's really not up to me and
my my internet should be should be
pretty great now
so it's not it's not my doing if there
is any funny business
regarding the uh the
uh the connection all right so what do
we have here
uh nice black is up a piece and
also up up on time should be
should be pretty straightforward but in
bullet it never is
i don't think the the grand masters in
the tournament are
known and uh unless the first gentleman
that we saw
uh is a mystery person you know uh
uh using a a zero da um
you know i think we're we're in for a
treat definitely
if you're hearing some bikes here and
there like motorcycles there's uh
there's a race tomorrow
um uh happening in you know
where i live so people are probably
trying out their motorcycles
how do you know someone is cheating well
obviously they play great and you lose
and of course
there's no way that someone can beat you
so they are they are
[Music]
that means that they are cheating
hey my mother chris thanks for the
contribution man
appreciate it yeah i don't i don't know
what to call it but
i i i saw that people call it a azerotha
uh and i i like it you know
the gentleman really changed the course
of chess history with that one
yeah they don't use uh electric
motorcycles
all right so where is our mystery person
from round one
who whoever it is uh all right let's see
let's see this one uh it is the next uh
game being suggested okay i thought we
were gonna have an evans gambit but
but no it's uh just a rui lopez it's a
false alarm
yeah it's a bullet uh of course there
there will be missed mates all over the
all over the place
best player itamar against the
shank shankar deep 2006
all right so that white is really
pushing that a pawn
should be should be good
similar similar to my game that i played
uh
when i uh uh maybe it was the second
bullet game that i played with since we
started the stream
uh but yeah a lot of a lot of queen side
and king side action
all right michael castano says that he
will
uh he will do another contribution for
fourth place so whoever finishes fourth
uh will also receive a prize plus also
uh there is a
mystery prize uh for whoever he picks uh
and
it will be a person who played many many
games but did not achieve a great result
he says that this reminds him of of
himself and that he wishes for
such a person to receive this prize so
very very noble of him
yes i i turned 51 two days ago that that
is true
you know it's not easy doing this at 51.
all right so here we have a nice rook
end game uh with white being up two
pawns and
this is uh winning for white but uh of
course now that black
uh got hold of the second rank with the
rooks anything
anything is possible okay now black is
up a rook
a rook against three pawns so usually
rooks will win but this is bullet so
anything goes here
can i cover a bob dylan game um
if if oh a nice mate is on the board
uh yeah if you if you give me the moves
nice i don't look a day over 60 thanks
man
all right so what do we have here all
right
shanka deep uh really destroying
everyone
with with the with the berserks and he's
leading the tournament
all right well we said we're gonna check
out some okay
manir mandia is playing so let's check
out his game as well
uh against uh against grandmaster pop so
let's see how that goes
they've played many games so far uh
mandia is
leading by a point so we'll see if he
can extend the extent his lead
thanks guys thank you for the for the
great
wishes
alright so what do we have here
uh no berserking action which means that
they are both
interested in playing a good game
uh when is the new saga beginning after
we finish the morphe saga i am planning
to continue morphe saga
fairly soon uh but we'll see no i'm not
61 i'm 51.
i mean your your comment has been read
your comment okay what was that what was
the bishop here
nice okay uh i think
uh manir uh
played this very well he doesn't have a
queen
or rather pop doesn't have a queen we'll
see we'll see what happens here
so it's a bishop fair and the rook bear
against the rook and the queen
okay this is gonna be this is gonna be
good
according to wikipedia i'm 34 yeah but
people you know people
will write anything on wikipedia
that's that's how wikipedia works
who will be the next saga i don't know
people will decide that i
i mean i'm gonna i'm gonna ask uh people
what they want but
my guess is either alexander yejin or or
judith polgar but could be could be
anyone really
all right and manir
wins here here very nicely done very
nicely done
yeah uh the uh the rooks will get
exchanged and then the queen will be
stronger than the bishop and the rook
and also
pop has only 16 seconds so this was a
a very nice victory all right uh who do
we have
uh let's go to the deeper parts of the
of the table
uh who do we have who who is being
showcased
all right we we haven't seen this one
zavin chesmud versus international
master roshika evgeny
yeah having kids at 51 is a great
achievement it
it definitely is yeah all right so
black is not black is not happy here
uh but we'll see that that white king is
also feeling
feeling the draft uh i'm pretty sure
that's not the expression
hey lex lex how do you manage the time
to join uh every stream you're like the
busiest person i know
thanks for for the contribution man and
yes when you
when you visit croatia you you you you
can even join me for a a nice stream
uh we we could discuss some you know
chess
and you know how how how how how are
your plans going uh
with building yourself a girlfriend and
you know
the sky's the limit
ah the time control in the arena is two
minutes two minutes
plus zero second increment
my videos are popular in the asmr
community
i i seriously doubt that i don't know
how that would
how that would work
like i've never actually seen an asmr
video
uh it's i mean i know what they are it's
like when people touch the microphone
and it produces
fancy sounds and then people enjoy that
uh but
uh yeah maybe maybe chess could also do
that yeah
all right so what do we what do we have
here all right this is
this can go either way because it's
bullet so
was that furuja incognito in first game
no i
imagine if playing that he's playing the
title arena
uh i i don't think that would be him
incognito
do i think nepo has a chance of beating
magnus of course
of course everyone has a chance uh
karakin had a chance fabi had a chance
uh
i mean he's there so obviously he has a
chance but uh
you know anything uh more than that uh
it's hard to say
i i think it all comes down to how how
motivated will will magnus be
and i imagine nepo will be extremely
motivated
but you know hard to say
all right let's i'm trying to find a
game that's just starting out and maybe
maybe features the evans gambit although
uh
not nope nope nope nope yeah these are
all games that are already wow i
i just see that every player that i
choose i i play the game against him
that's how many bullet games i've played
okay all right so yeah here we have one
all right one that's
kind of starting out let's let's see
this one i
was uh all right so it was a nice rule
lopez let's let's check out this one
between a few uh lower rated gentlemen
hey jay anjakar uh thank thanks for the
contribution man
yeah the baby baby is the best uh if any
of you are considering
uh having a baby you know it's it's
definitely the best
uh you you know that i'm definitely not
51 how
how would you know that i mean the the
wikipedia really
says uh you know everything
people even people even edit wikipedia
for fun
can i play your mother at a game of
chess i i
definitely could ha
is she is she good at chess
firuja versus so round one of the pair
is gran chester
uh well was that like a decisive game
i mean it's uh it's pretty weird that i
haven't covered it
uh let me just quickly check what are
you talking about
uh furuja versus so
oh i probably missed it because it it
was a draw but
i will check it out yeah seems like it
was uh quite a quite a violent game
yeah i will i will definitely check it
out hello
sorry sorry about that uh i'm just
trying to
okay let's get rid of that
all right there we go
[Music]
the birthday variation of the semi-slab
hikaru said he didn't play against
alireza
i have no idea what that means
would the old masters have a chance
against the machines no
if okay maybe uh but it would be a very
interesting game
i mean it would be it would be
incredible to
to hear what for example capablanca
would say if he
played against uh let's say alpha zero
and of course that he didn't know
that if a human was portraying the moose
what would his
thought process be how would the how
would capablanca you know
uh convince himself that this is normal
what what just happened
it would be um i
i don't know it'd be unimaginable
pigue all right pigle let's see a game
by pigoo who is winning all the games
and berserking all the games
let's see if pigou can uh continue in on
this path of carnage
bobby fischer would destroy alpha zero
yes our our good silicon friend
kappa blanca vs trey ball 1929 yeah uh i
i've heard of this game i just
i just can't remember which one it is
but i i or or maybe i would just
recommended it by
uh by a few people by now so that's why
i remember it and again it was a
swift victory by pigoo all right
so my only hope is that people are not
uh cheating in this tournament because
they will be eliminated by the end of
the tournament and they're just uh
you know ruining uh the fun for for
everyone else but
uh uh you can never
you know you can never prevent such
things so we'll we'll see all right
let's find a nice game that's just
starting out
uh all right
asensio versus frosty panda 37
all right it's the the gentleman that
won that brilliancy
in the in the first round
uh robert bayern versus bobby fischer
yeah i'm pretty sure we covered that
big means something in chinese what what
is it what does it mean
josh losberg thank you for thank you for
such a
great great wishes man
how tall am i i am somewhat tall yes
191 centimeters to be exact
or last time i measured which was maybe
in high school so maybe i've
uh maybe i'm shorter now who knows you
know people do get shorter
yeah i know i can click with the middle
mouse button
but i just i i learned of that like
maybe two years ago and then i got so
used to using uh right click and left
click
that i never could you know uh
convince my brain to actually use the
the middle mouse button
yeah fischer versus spassky 1992 that is
something that i am definitely
covering uh at some point you know
there's time you know chess isn't going
anywhere
yes even luca i know where the places
work as part of owns a house
all right i'm uh all right
i i've just been uh informed by
uh by a certain gentleman that the the
second chapter of our manga
the age of kaiser has been released uh
and
i will provide you with the link but if
you uh
if you don't uh uh if you don't want to
wait you can
just go to my website uh agarmatter.com
and then go
to the manga and you will see chapter
two of age of kaiser
so for those of you who know what this
is and have uh seen
chapter one i think we released it uh
last year in october
maybe it was november and then we had a
bit of a bit of a break
and then uh well we're only releasing
the chapter two now but other chapters
will be released uh
uh much much quicker so for those of you
who who were eagerly
waiting for chapter two the chapter two
is now live
and it is uh very very different from
chapter one as you'll see but i will
make a separate video covering the age
of kaiser
chapter two of the manga so even if you
uh don't manage now uh you know no no
worries
you will you will be uh informed uh
appropriately all right uh someone
agat is the best all right i like that i
like that
nickname uh let's see let's see how he
does
no i never i never played professionally
yeah i'm i'm watching uh
i'm watching the euros uh if you're
referring to the european
football championship uh but only only
creation
uh games as you know i'm from croatia
hey john m welcome to excellent
subscribers the the greatest community
there ever was and will be uh we
really have no perks but we you know uh
we stick together and we enjoy chess
i'm just kidding you have a few you have
a few uh
emoticons so you can uh you know spam
those
there's not a lot but i am uh planning
on improving that
there are some great uh um some great uh
emotes are coming like the like the
zerota head
when someone plays a great uh great
engine move and you know stuff like that
norman faraz you you are noticed you are
noticed sir
yes david kimura says it will you have
the the little medal emotes
portugal lost germany one two to four
and it's uh
unfortunate someone someone wrote that
germany lost
yes the i i see the zerota head being
the most popular emote
yes there is also the chucky head yes
and now i i mean i i it was um
i i made the the emoticons one day and i
thought okay so now i'm just gonna
keep on adding them but i i stopped
streaming that uh
that often so i haven't um added anymore
but
you know they are they will come no
worries
all right so can agard is the best win
this
oh that's uh that's a pretty scary pawn
that's a pretty scary pawn but he is up
many pawns
so yeah it's a pretty weird position
okay white white will not be happy here
no i i'm sorry i didn't uh i missed your
comment uh i'm trying to
enjoy this uh amazing game
ah hikaru said that that game was not
played by him
uh i'm pretty sure that's not true
because
uh i checked on chess.com and uh it was
a game between the two of them
uh but i i said in the video that it was
played two days ago but it was actually
played in march so
uh probably why he was confused uh but
the the
the game most certainly did happen if it
didn't uh
i you know uh the jokes on me but i will
check it was a suggestion from a
subscriber
so unless he unless he really tricked me
um should be should be i mean a legit
game
but yeah okay in the video i said it was
played like two days ago when in fact
was played in march
uh but you know we're here to enjoy the
game not not dates
uh but i will check i will check thank
you for for mentioning this
how how did i think of uh of making the
manga
uh well we we actually discussed that
many times
uh but we will uh we will
uh get get back to it you know all right
so here we have a very nice game between
our leader asensio
who who after losing the game now is
again crushing everyone
what's a manga okay
is my baby a gm uh getting there
getting there yeah
ing asylum uh five years wow
that's uh pretty much when i started the
channel very very happy to hear that
all right so
let me just check okay we're going to
check this later i'm also very
interested in
if this gentleman is uh
is known i've never heard of the of the
handle
ah valentina valentina is uh enjoying
the seaside
with her husband and family having
having a beer all right
so white really really
playing a spectacular game
or is he well he really
okay and uh we have a resignation white
white is victorious
nice the knight cannot go anywhere wow
it's pretty pretty crazy stuff
pretty crazy stuff
all right okay
agad is the best is playing against
ascencio let's let's see this uh
incredible battle
how do you know why grand masters make
certain moves
uh well you don't you you know
you think about what could happen and
then you
you know think about it some more and
you're probably going to be wrong but
you know that's that it's the journey
that matters not not the destination
is it possible to cheat in bullet i i
don't see how you would do it i mean i'm
sure it's
you know the technology we have
currently allows us to do it but
it would be it would be very sad if
someone you know
came to a bulletin book to a bullet
tournament and
used an engine but it's uh you know uh
any talk of engine is i think very
inappropriate
uh because it just ruins uh
it ruins uh you know when everything is
done in good spirits so hopefully
none of that will will be needed here
how old will my daughter be when she
first beats me at chess
uh i don't know i don't think i'm i'm
one of those people that you know
will uh keep beating her until she you
know uh cries her eyes out
so it's hard to say maybe
maybe even the first game
[Music]
you're putting your money on ascencio
but agad is the best is doing
good work here look at those
those pieces look at that
that rook here not doing all that much
oh
that was nice okay so black is upper
rook but
yeah this is this is a matter of seconds
basically
can i speak any arabic nope no i can't
i always i always wished i did but but i
don't
all right uh so agat is the best was not
able to win this one but he was
uh playing very very impressively
alright so who do we have next let's uh
go uh
all right over 4 000 players 4191 player
um who do we do do we like uh
do we like a handle let's see some
let's see some cool handles
beast of sagamo i have no idea what
sagamo is but
i like the i like the handle if he gets
a game anytime soon
all right let's see if maneer can beat
asensio while we're waiting
hero merlin is the best player in the
world
favorite chess champion i think my uh
you know my interface pretty much uh
speaks for itself
almeida is actually here he's just uh
sleeping on the floor he
he sometimes sleeps on the floor
sometimes he doesn't you know he's a
he's a dog that that's how dogs ro roll
ah sagamo is a town in nigeria okay
thank you for that thank you for
increasing my not
not so vast knowledge of nigerian cities
all right so this is uh now
this is now a game
manir actually actually berserked him so
there's that and
okay that's uh that knight is really
doing good work here yeah i think uh
i think that's pretty much it or is it
or is it wow this is a this is a good
game
okay should that pass pawn start
marching forward
most most definitely with eight seconds
on the clock
okay this is this is too intense for me
all right so the bishop is uh
okay wow okay wow
and monir resigns wow seems no one can
beat ascencio
and he's only i know he he also plays
blitz okay he also plays blitz
all right that was uh that was really
really
really intense all right is beast of
sagamo still not playing
so some players can't really get to get
a game
grand master chameleon oh vincent kymer
is playing no kidding
vincent came he's a bit late but i think
he's uh he's ready to crush everyone
hi it's max deutsch yeah it could very
well be max deutsch yeah
let's see let's see how vincent does i i
didn't know vincent was in leeches
yeah i mean i would i will cover fisher
versus spasky 1992.
that's uh no no worries that that is
definitely happening
all right what oh that's that's nasty
oh
oh yeah oh how can black
how can black get out of this one
wow oh that's that's nice
wow nice nice rook sacrifice
okay it's uh the only move
i guess and what after queen c2
queen cat okay so he had to give up the
rook to
prevent being checkmated but
it's pretty pretty crazy stuff
all right so i i think vince will have
to resort to flagging now
we'll we'll see what happens
yeah maybe it's nick will come out yeah
yeah i don't think that's uh that's
going anywhere anytime soon
thank you for for such uh well for such
uh
great uh great wishes uh
i don't know i don't know if if you
really wanted to
wanted that but i i do wish you uh
have a have a great birthday whenever it
is
and that you you enjoy it
hey akash welcome to excellent
subscribers the the greatest team in the
world
all right so vince is still in the game
here this is
pretty incredible that he can still play
this
oh that he hung a rook what no
okay so now yeah okay so he's still
gonna try and do this
and now push the pawn yeah okay what
what oh my oh man
oh wow and wins vince is going to win
this
he's going to flag him yeah he just has
to use every
every time a different square with the
queen so it's not a
another draw by a three-fold repetition
by any chance but he actually won this
wow
the super impressive really really
impressive
how he just gave up a rook for that
incredible well just uh
just a spectacular game akash
welcome and enjoy enjoy all the emotes
all four of them uh just kidding more
more
are coming
uh as a birthday resolution please read
harry potter books 2-6 how do you know i
only read the first one
how do you know i only read the first
one
and i i really enjoyed the first one all
right let's see this one we said we were
gonna check out some
uh games from the lower parts of the
table
thanks man yeah lekko student
that was uh that was a truly an
impressive game
really impressive game
[Music]
i told in a video that i only read the
first one oh okay
i thought it was weird that uh someone
knew that
can i see which country ascensio is from
yeah okay i i'm gonna check but i
i don't think um i don't think it says
i think it's uh it's like a mystery
account
yeah now now i i mostly remember to turn
down my
my volume so no sorry about that in uh
in the new videos but
uh it's uh after i moved to this house
now i have a bigger table
so it would it would take much more you
know to go
under the table and fix it during the
video so i i forced myself to remember
it
before the video but i still forget
sometimes
like uh not a lot sometimes
how many boards can i play in my head
on a good day on a good day one
alright so a nice rock end game equal
material
and uh let's see how how black does this
all right white is going for the greedy
maneuver
he he wants it all he wants it all
yeah yeah i've seen uh pragananda and
then uh nico sarin got into the fiji
wild cards
uh yeah i mean it's uh it's gonna be
gonna be a
a much better event with with two or two
such fine gentlemen playing in it
no i don't think i am playing any over
the board tournaments anytime soon
uh too much
too busy
uh at the moment but let's see yeah a
sense you're still crushing everyone
that's
uh really really amazing all right so
uh let's see someone who we still
haven't seen
heisenberg from turkey all right so it's
still
uh kind of in the beginning let's check
it out against nami namitibir singh
i should turn on my air conditioning all
right man
it's actually not that warm here but uh
i i had had a lot to do today and
uh you know we had some friends uh you
know
we we had a few beers and you know you
know how it goes
uh it's not not all from the heat
all right so let's see uh uh as usual
the title player always berserks
adams greetings man
yeah we'll see we'll see who this
mystery person is
but uh
he seems to be he seems to be doing uh
incredibly well
uh only losing first game and then uh
oh he got a draw now he he got a draw
now so
uh all right well let's uh let's
continue in in this fashion
it's playing against ensemo
who i've played six times uh probably
probably in bullet
uh let's see how how it goes
guys not not everyone who plays well is
nikhil kamat come on
all right then he wins the queen nice
[Music]
oh he even he even got a rating point
for that okay that was uh
that was very clean he spent like 14 14
seconds on that
uh pretty pretty awesome
uh all right all right uh
vincent is already uh in in the 15th
place all right let uh
we're going to check out more games by
vince uh
but this one is already finished so uh
we're gonna return to that
okay who who is just starting the game
uh derem okay uh
here's a here's a pretty pretty fun
position
uh yeah
would i be interested in organizing an
over the board tournament in the future
uh of course i would be interested in
many things but
uh it's hard uh hard to do anything now
with
with the coronavirus and everything
thanks for the contribution man
in in bengali
thanks a lot man
what's my least favorite opening to play
against
uh uh pretty sure it's the french
defense
yeah uh especially when someone plays it
really well
would i rather croatia does well in uh
football or in chess
but where where would croatia do well in
chess
i mean there it's not like okay the the
there's the chess olympia but
uh uh croatia did well
in the chess olympiad and also in the in
the world
uh football championship so croatia did
very well in in both
um but uh you know
although i'm i prefer chess myself uh it
would make more people happy if
you know croatia did better in football
so i'm gonna go with football on this
one
chess players are always uh you know
happy
they don't need any anything extra
all right vikki mishra
um phoenix let's try to find the game
that's only starting out no one no one
is playing the evan's gambit
what what is this madness
abhijit all right this game is just
starting uh we can check out
this one
oh uh it's actually a different one but
uh but okay
you hate two plus so uh i'm actually not
a fan myself
but uh i thought more more people would
come because those who play bullet can
always just berserk and
they will get a bullet game uh but uh
they they don't want to play a three
minute game because that's i mean that
that's too long
all right what is this captures with now
the okay that
and now
uh okay that's a free rook free rook
hanging okay he doesn't want it
is uh it's chilling uh you know on the
on the lower floors of the house
f7 was hanging since three moves yeah
uh will i cover fabi versus alireza game
i i have not seen the fabi versus all it
is a game i
uh i only saw that one game today
uh but uh i have not seen fabi versus
all it is i can check it out now really
quickly
uh what round was it
oh this one that ended in a draw was a
really good game
all right i'm gonna go uh tomorrow
morning i'm gonna go through through
some of them to see
what happened
no it's not too late to join the arena
but maybe maybe it's a bit too late to
win the arena
panda thank you for the thank you for
everything panda and thank you for this
wonderful t-shirt as you can see panda
uh got me this uh t-shirt it's actually
uh
a snake comprised of the words uh
captures so it's a you know a snake made
of letters or maybe it's not a snake
it's maybe sort of a lizard
uh but uh you know it says captures so
it's a it's really a captures monster
uh it's one of a kind so you know i'm
the only one that has it i'm very happy
with it
uh you know i go around town and people
are like wow that's uh that's a very
nice shirt and i'm like
yeah i mean i know so
thanks for that panda it's a really
really really nice one
today i actually had the visitors from
uh from a different country and they
were
they were very impressed with the shirt
all right so very nicely done uh
let's go back here to see if asensio is
still uh you know
keeping it clean
uh seems so yeah seems so
let me just quickly check here
remember since uh 9th of june 2020. so
it's a very old account so
i don't think the the i don't think
there's any funny business here it's
over a year old account so it's not like
it's a new account that has been created
so no worries
what if my daughter rebels and she says
that she prefers dominoes
ah you know you uh no no one says that
she
she she must play chess
my my grandfather always uh said that i
have to play chess i have to play chess
i have to just and then i
never played chess because he just
wanted me to play chess
so not how it works
yeah yeah i got torino uh argent
motorino created
the the the captures monster uh panda
converted it to
uh to vectors and had it printed so it
was a it was a joint uh
effort
why am i not playing well that's that's
kind of the point of this uh
to showcase your games uh so whenever
you play a brilliant game like we've
seen
many many in this tournament uh then
everyone can be very impressed
but yeah that that first game of the
tournament when it started that was
i mean wow that was so crazy
and this one also i mean what what what
is happening here
this bishop is not
i mean okay okay ah okay he he resigned
all right the queen is out nothing to
to do here uh vince is
how is vincent doing let's check up on
vincent he's still
on a super winning streak although he
joined a bit late
but there's still over an hour to the
tournament so
okay so here a nice grandmaster clash
we'll see what happens in this one all
right let me just
check yeah abby abby
is reminding me that in my video that i
will do for the manga that i should also
mention the stories yeah
you guys if you like stories and if
you've been following what we've been
doing with the manga so far
uh there's a separate section of the
manga regarding the stories that are not
currently a part of the manga
but are you know just as incredible if
not
better and uh you know you if you have
some spare time or if you you know need
something to really enjoy
i would very much recommend these
stories uh so it's all on the website
agatmatra.com uh so it's all free you
know you can
enjoy it uh uh really really awesome
stuff but
uh i will mention it uh in tomorrow's
video separately so you know don't worry
if you if you've missed it
[Music]
yeah the the the manga we've created
last year the age of kaiser
now you know it has everything it has
robots it has
chess it has love it has a philosophy
you know uh very very deep uh
um you know i i'm not gonna spoil it for
you you will have to
you will have to see it for yourselves
all right so uh
black up a pawn but uh here it's hard to
say that it will
mean all that much especially since it's
it's a bullet game and i mean
look at this crazy position
of course huge shout out to carlo and
pharman
you you guys are are the best
all right so how is uh how is it vince
the
to proceed here
all right so now a rook end game uh
where now
white is up upon wow how how'd that
happen
it's pretty crazy stuff
oh that that that was that was very nice
he tried to get him to trade but
of course it doesn't work
okay so if uh if it will be enough time
for vincent i think he will be able to
win this but if not
oh that's a that's a oh that's an ugly
position
that's very ugly
okay captures alpaso and he resigns of
course
it is plenty of time for vince yes
vincent
uh the the destroyer
still with a with a perfect result i
think the only one in the top 10 with a
perfect result but he joined late
uh but what are you gonna do all right
so what do we have uh
what do we have here
okay what what just happened
speed monkey all right here's a
nice position it's uh
uh he's from the from the pirate land
now you can actually choose to be a
pirate on leeches that's that's actually
pretty cool
how old is vincent now i actually have
no idea
i i want to say something something
stupid but could be
could be like uh maybe
19 i really don't know or maybe less
probably probably less probably less
yeah
like maybe 17 no maybe even less i
really don't know if any of you know do
share in the comments
what chance do i give nepo in the
upcoming championship games
um i don't know it's
uh i i would say
i would say maybe
like i i would say maybe 50 50 with uh
with
all all depends on how motivated magnus
will be
like i said nipple will be extremely
motivated but
we'll see how motivated magnus will be
uh not not only in playing the games but
also in preparing for the games
so i don't know
we'll see ah he's 16
okay
so for for those of you who are
wondering uh vincent is
16.
if any if you're hearing some snoring
that's uh that's meadow in the
background
uh he's uh you know he he snores that's
that's what kind of a guy he is all
right asensio still crushing everyone
all right let's see another one can he
can he do it against the speed monkey
speed monkey is actually playing faster
than ascencio
or no it's a senior ah senior i've been
mispronouncing our leader's name for the
entire tournament
dog dog snore yeah dog snore yeah
yeah that doesn't matter i mean fabi uh
fabi played incredibly well against
magnus but uh
you know when it came to speed chess to
rapid games then it
uh was pretty much a one-sided battle
and uh
if anyone came close it was it was it
was definitely kayaking
he was the one that got got close to
winning
who would win between max deutsch and
nicole kamath
uh that's uh that's a tough one i don't
know
it all depends how much time max deutsch
would have to prepare
could a monkey become a grand master uh
i i don't see i i don't see that
happening but you know
uh if they ever managed to you know
improve their their abilities like in
the planet of the apes could it could
happen yeah
a spaceman spiff welcome to the the
excellent subscribers team
the the greatest team in the world
welcome
finally finally got his name right i
finally got whose name right
all right so uh speed monkey is uh
giving a senior uh
some problems as he he's very fast but
okay so now it's uh two rooks against
the bishop and the rook and the black
has three pawns
okay
yeah okay i think it's uh by now it's
i think it's pretty clear that it's uh
uh uh senor is a very strong grand
master
so that's uh
that's not even a question anymore so
now it's or maybe
maybe it's a mystery person you know
someone playing from his basement
that never played chess before and just
crushing everyone
could be
not uh
thanks for the contribution man who's
the best chess player who never became
world champion
uh of course the legend uh vasily van
chuk
there is no other there there is no
other
okay there are there are a lot of people
who could claim to be that uh
okay that that that works that also
works
great great game okay so i don't think
no one is uh
no one will be able to catch up to a
senior
but i could be wrong it's just that he
after losing that first game he hasn't
lost a single one
so it's pretty pretty cool and a first
game he lost
to who
ah the grand master chess mood okay
ah so that that that's the game he lost
oh wow
nice nice nice nice that the the
greatest game
uh that we've seen in the tournament so
far was the first game
that our leader lost uh so that's nice
and also uh four thousand
and five hundred and forty four players
in the tournament so far
all right who do we have here chess
world
national master italian machine all
right let's see
national master italian machine
thank you for the for the happy birthday
wishes homie thanks thanks a lot man
uh no no one knows who is that who is a
senior
it's uh obviously a mystery
what's meadow's favorite treat uh
that's actually a really good question
because i don't think anyone knows
uh he just eats everything like there's
there's nothing you can give him that he
won't eat
so it's uh it would be hard to pinpoint
his actual
favorite because he he just eats
everything
i have from 100 players to 5 000 players
yeah
all right so let's see how the italian
machine does
all right so we've uh we've reached the
second half of the tournament
and so far things are going pretty great
first place i think is kind of settled
of course many things can happen but if
this continues i don't know
this is uh seems to be a most
dominant performance by uh a senior
whoever whoever this person
mystery person is uh but uh the other
places are are still
in grasp a weather guru thanks for the
contribution man
i'm very very happy i was i was able to
you know
uh get get you to join and join our uh
happy team
of of chess enthusiasts
no there was never a a a match between
magnus and alpha zero
what is the what what is the what what
is the name of the software i'm using to
watch uh
the games it's uh i'm i'm using google
chrome
but if you're maybe referring to what
i'm using to stream it i use the obs
open broadcasting software
no i have not had the privilege of
meeting uh vaseline vancouver
he was in zagreb uh many times as he's
playing for the
for the creation team in the league but
i i did not
yet visit uh
when when he was he was playing i know i
know some people that
went there and they they had a photo
with him and uh you know
good for them but i i missed it
unfortunately
so uh that is something that i plan to
rectify
uh as soon as possible uh maybe maybe
even convince him to join me for
for a nice stream
yes i have i've been to split many times
yes
alright so italian machine wins
uh with uh with time on the clock to
spare with 45 seconds
uh so very nicely done all right so
let's uh
see oh i got his best really doing well
uh
i i've seen ronaldinho was uh
in the tournament but
he does not appear to be playing i know
he
uh
he registered but but he's not no longer
playing
uh where is our where's our vincent
vincent uh disappeared oh no it's here
ah he lost and then he paused oh man
who did he lose to to
to to ferocious lion
what what are you gonna do
all right so our next one is being
played let's see how
if vincent will be able to bounce back
hey he himanshu satwik thanks for the
contribution man
and for the birthday wishes
all right so let's see if he can if he
can bounce back with this one
those are really really quick moves
quick quick good moves
viruja's line what's uh what's the first
line
uh-huh hoping for a senior versus
vincent oh i i think vincent has to win
at least a few more games to the reach
uh
to play against the senior but yeah it
would be it would be uh definitely
something that i would enjoy
uh seeing and it's not uh you know the
games are much more serious if it's a
one minute game then okay
i mean a good game can happen but if
it's two minute game then
you know it will probably be a very uh
top level game
ah asensio is playing football this
evening okay
ah sorry panda sorry panda
yeah i did not uh i did not connect to
ferugia to ferocious
uh but yeah it's a weird that i didn't
because even uh
even i use the the the the word play
at some point uh in uh in one of my
video titles i think
so my bad on that one hey ryan brooke
thanks
thank you for the uh contribution man
and thank you for the birthday wishes
glad you are glad you're enjoying the
content
oh senior lost what
uh what is this
against video master heisenberg and then
drew a game against
chess mode all right so uh it's been a
it's been an impressive streak but it
seems to
uh have come to an end uh we'll see if
it can continue but he still has a very
very impressive lead 125 points to 101
so
that's that's impressive
all right let's see let's see what do we
have uh who did we
not see mitra ba international master
mitra from
india
all right ferocious lion still playing
some sort of a gruesome end game all
right let's see
let's see this one it's just about to
start
bishwa hacker versus matthew matthew g
all right
ron bissaro thank you thanks for the
contribution man
uh i that's actually not a dry sense of
humor that's
you know people sometimes i say weird
things and people people think it's a
it's
it's a dry sense of humor but really
really it's not
i'm i'm not even kidding
is there any form of chest betting i
think there is like every form of chest
betting
uh like i mean i've never checked but
i'm pretty sure
you know websites that allow betting
will allow you to bet on chess games
maybe not all of them but
hey actually jane thanks for the
contribution man thanks a lot
do i have any more tall games yes but
i'm uh keeping them
uh safe you know for for when we need
them
if we covered all of them now uh we we
wouldn't have anything to cover
so you know i really went crazy with the
with the tile games with the fisher
games with the nez medina of games and
then
uh we had to you know stop briefly to
cover what's currently happening in the
world
and you know do some very very old sagas
but then at some point we will
of course uh get back to that and then
at some point
i will have to remake all of the games
in super high quality
uh because that's what what you should
do
happy birthday rudra for your brother
there you go man
all right so bishop hacker
bishop hacker playing really really
impressively here
uh against an international master
matthew g who is down to eight seconds
on the clock
and that's uh i think this is going to
be enough for him
uh but we'll see not a lot but
he okay now he's going going for the
the bishop harass very nice
okay but uh he can't do it yeah
okay now he grabs the pawn and that's it
all right with three seconds if he
manages this that's super impressive
okay he doesn't want to push the pawn
because if he pushes the pawn then the
bishop captures it
and two seconds will not be enough to
deliver checkmate uh
but he he can do it maybe oh this is
such a flag fest
oh wow
wow he's playing like five moves uh
every single move to be able to play
this with one second on the clock
yeah he's gonna have to give up the rook
not just so he doesn't lose the game
[Music]
okay wow this is
and he loses no it's a draw it's a draw
it's a draw
uh i guess it was a 50 move rule
oh no no white can't win okay due to
insufficient material
of course yeah
oh yeah pretty crazy this was this was
this was insane
okay that was that was uh really really
intense
all right vince lost another game to to
manier
uh who do we have aside from the aside
from the top 10.
uh i i do not know who this is
this certain grand master from
azerbaijan
vugar rasholov all right against uh
against chess phobia
in uh you know what can only be
described as a
really weird game but okay it's a queen
against some
a queen against the the mary army
thanks for the contribution man
uh yeah if you're referring to the
previous game white can't theoretically
win with a help mate
but we i guess the that
that doesn't count i
i think so
all right so
black is uh black is gonna capture the
g2 no he's not
and now the bishop falls okay so and
then you win the pawn
so this is a crazy position
can i please explain how how do people
become grand master international master
you play
oh oh wow oh that that hurt
uh you have to play uh many games
against many strong international
opponents so when elo rating
and then uh when your elo passes
a certain threshold it's of course
different for
for every every title and then you are
awarded the title of uh
international master or grandmaster and
also not just the rating you also have
to collect norms
so you know there's that it's not easy
but people
people do it
what's my favorite animal except the dog
i don't know if uh oh yeah i know it's
it's the pig yeah definitely the pig
pigs pigs are awesome
all right oh very nice
black timed out white is victorious
so chess phobia for the win
all right who do we have
uh in semo
oh you can you can also play uh
under a leeches flag okay
[Music]
i'm pretty sure i knew that but maybe i
just forgot
all right here's a here's a fun position
happening here in ezekiel greg versus uh
fc kosice
hey thanks a lot man
uh what food from my country would i
recommend i'm not i'm really not
the the person to recommend this but uh
i don't know it's i don't even know what
food is croatian food because here it's
not uh
most of the food that people say is
croatian food is actually not but it's
from you know
uh surrounding countries so i don't know
what would be like uh
like a croatian meal
yeah i don't i don't think uh tesco is
is creation or or buddhic yeah
that that's not creation
a senior lost another game okay
so the stream is ending
usually people say a lion is their
favorite animal yeah i don't know
i i take pig or a lion any day
what are my thoughts on creation results
in the euros uh i mean
wha wha what what thoughts could there
be
isn't raki a croatian drink
no i don't think it is no i don't think
it is
uh it's a it's a very good drink but i
don't think it's the you know
it's actually creation
yeah yeah okay maybe that
but i don't consider that a dish
shahad epstein thank you for the
contribution man
big big uh big shout out to to you and
your brother
who are uh strict followers
how to become a strict follower and
always
enjoy the show thanks a lot man
strict follower i don't think i've ever
ever met a strict follower
can i speak a bit of italian i probably
could
if i tried but i'm not going to
ah raqqa is a bulgarian drink okay
if you say so i mean i i believe you
all right ezekiel greg loses and we go
back to our
uh to our table to see
all right so assenio still still
with a very very impressive lead i don't
know
fide master heisenberg also also doing
incredibly well with 116 points
uh against jonas
and black just resigned okay so we we
were
a bit late to the party here
chess moved grand master chess mode in
third place currently
uh against the national master italian
machine
i imagine from italy no he uh
italian machine is actually from canada
if you were wondering
will you ever see the morphe saga again
of course
we are not done with the morphe saga
worry not
is a very impressive player himself he
is currently just snoring behind me so
uh there's that uh vincent in eighth
place
uh matthew g in seventh uh rosh kevgeny
in
ninth and uh
toby from norway uh in tenth place
who actually have a positive score
against him nice
in in a bullet game that's what i like
to see
all right so who is
uh in a in a crazy position okay this is
a pretty crazy position
uh and heisenberg berserked so
let's see let's see how this goes
am i planning for more uh spielman games
uh not planning but i'm not against it
thank you yugoslav gamer i i i often
think that myself you know
in silence
who's winning magnus or nipple uh
for the moment i i think uh
well they're not playing but uh nippo is
doing incredibly well
against other players not not against
magnus
uh chucky is an absolute legend there is
no other way of putting that
do i change diapers yes unfortunately
uh i asked her but she uh she simply
couldn't do it she's only a week old and
she was like i just can't do it so i i
had to do it
a senior big eerie i don't know
does gear even play on leeches i know
uh i know he played like
at some point but i don't know if he if
he continued
ah okay so he is the who is the most
natural talent uh
in the chess world yeah if every great
player from history came with no
knowledge of chess uh was only shown the
rules and asked the play who would win
the first tournament
that's uh that's uh
that's a good one i don't know who
uh probably i don't know probably
reshevsky but could be it could be
anyone
how i react samiraina and hikaru stream
what is what is there to react on did
something happen there
all right so assenio still uh just you
know destroying everyone
all right let's see let's see how he how
he finishes this uh
this one
so it's a pretty intense end game and
he's probably gonna sacrifice something
here at some point
mvl is underperforming in classical and
now losing uh points in rapid
uh i mean it's always uh it's hard to
say it's hard to say because um
when you have so so many strong players
uh
in one tournament and then you have like
one bad tournament you're gonna lose
rating points and
i don't think anything is happening it's
just that uh
uh
you know
uh i mean it happens
do i like scotch opening yeah i
i used to play it a lot now not so much
because uh when i play d4 and i and i go
for the scotch
there is no way to go for the evans
gambit after you know you you play the
scotch
so that's uh that's always an issue
uh we still do not know who asenu is
yeah i am planning to bring the podcast
back but
probably not in that uh scenario that i
i uh did the two uh podcasts with hikaru
and mvl
in uh probably a different one um
because that one uh i i made before the
the the covet 19 and i thought you know
people would just
you know come to my place and be guests
and then you know we'd
uh have some fun but you know now
because everything is online there
really is no point
in having a setup like that so i'm
probably going to do it differently but
i still
am planning to continue it
how many gigabytes in my king usb pen
drive
uh uh in this one yeah
i haven't uh
showcased it in a while but it's uh 32
and uh it's not 64.
because you also need the the other king
and then it's 64 gigabytes
uh when is the evans gambit arena uh all
right maybe for
maybe for next one we we do the evans
gambit arena
will i find out who asenu is if
he wins and i pay him uh i don't know if
if he prefers to remain anonymous then i
don't see why
why i would i mean everyone uh has uh
everyone has a right to be anonymous
if they wish so i mean i will probably
have to do it you know just in case uh
in order to avoid any funny business but
other than that
uh you know i will not uh reveal his
identity to anyone
who is my favorite niche medina or tal
uh
tal is always my favorite always the
number one but uh
you know rasheed is uh is
legend so you know i i would hate to
you know have to choose between the two
of them
it's just that you know uh having one is
great having the other is great having
both of them together
that's that's the dream hey adam genesis
in the chat happy saturday to you as
well man
uh very very happy for for the release
of the age of kaiser
uh will be will be very interesting to
see
uh after after people have enjoyed it uh
you know to read up on some of the
[Laughter]
comments
uh will i be playing anytime soon in the
tournament like like an over the board
uh yes uh we are our uh
our league is currently uh starting not
currently but in some i think in a few
weeks is starting so i will be playing
some over the board chess yes
karpov said chess is everything uh well
he could be he could be right i mean
he's uh
uh his entire life he's been uh you know
doing uh
i i think uh exclusively uh chess
related things so
could be do i have a mac
no i i don't
with 4 000 plus participants looking for
potential fourth price candidate
all right michael castano that that
sounds like a plan
we are very close to five thousand so uh
you know
if you guys are still interested in
joining uh do join
uh so we can have five thousand people
chances are you will not win the
tournament because uh you know
the gentleman leading the tournament is
uh
very rude to everyone he's just crushing
everyone
is chess addictive to you yeah i think
it is to
uh to most people
when will i cover 13 year old magnus
versus karpov
uh yeah okay i think i covered magnus vs
carpo when he was 14
i i did not cover the one when he where
he was 13 yeah
[Music]
carp of the snake eyes
how many chess games are possible uh i
i don't have an opinion in this sign
it's like the i mean it's the it's a
known number
uh although it's only an approximation
uh it's uh so i i
i haven't really studied it so it's like
uh it's like a known number but not
really
that number so it's somewhere around
that number plus or minus
maybe a few zeros
gaza midori thanks for the contribution
man and for the
for the birthday wishes how do i say
this in your tongue
uh you would say you would say so
in you know in creation
[Music]
yeah uh a lot of people are asking for
me to show the rematch uh spasky versus
fisher and uh
i will definitely do that yeah
that will require a bit more uh a bit
more
studying as i have not studied that much
so so much in depth because uh when i
was preparing for
uh for the bobby fischer saga i was
using some three books which were
very very uh detailed uh
for this one i i bought one book so
should be a good one but
i still haven't dug into it
how could spassky defeat thought so many
times
uh i mean tao played great
chess not uh you know not
uh can a consistent chess
maybe uh cheese all right
she's not playing
all right uh tactics forever
i remember this nickname from somewhere
tactics forever i have not played
against him but i i remember him from
somewhere
yeah are spectators allowed in the grand
chester croatia
uh uh two years ago they were of course
last year
there was no grand chester in croatia
but i don't know if they will be allowed
this year i'm pretty sure they will they
i mean they probably will sell tickets
um uh well we'll find out it's you know
it starts
very fairly soon uh i will be attending
uh
i uh last time they were here everyone
signed my chessboard so
hopefully i can get them to sign a new
one this time
uh you know collecting uh signed
chessboards
and a lot of players uh you know joined
from croatia and from some other
countries they come then
uh last uh last time that they were in
in croatia
uh you know we hung out uh you know
played some chess we had a few beers
so it was uh it was very nice
you get crushed by 1800s well that's not
not nothing to be ashamed of
who who hasn't lost a game to an 1800
who would i like to have dinner with uh
with a chest time with a time machine
uh i mean i i don't know
any any player you pick you're gonna
have a great time i mean imagine if you
if you if you got to
hang out with morphy i mean what can be
as good as that
all right
okay so white white doing very well
we'll see we'll see how this uh unfolds
croatia is a weirdly shaped country yes
it is
uh they say it looks like a lot of
things but mostly i remember when uh
i was still in school it was they said
like that it looks like a bird you know
flapping its wings
uh you know it's like uh you know a
shape you you can see whatever you want
to see
but you know i i i guess i guess you
could see a bird if you really wanted to
[Music]
is the lineup for zagreb known
you know probably most are maybe they
maybe they have to announce like
two more but also it could be that just
uh
the entire lineup is announced i haven't
checked yet
i usually check things right before they
happen
was croatia conquered by rome i
actually have no idea
uh parts of parts of croatia probably
were
because we uh you know the seaside
uh probably was i don't know about
the you know the the parts in the middle
or
or in the far north
what's my favorite thing about croatia
um i don't know uh really another
another very hard question
it's just uh there's uh
if i don't know i guess that maybe that
it's not
not overly developed so you know the the
things are still very nice and the
natural
yeah okay whoever says dubernik is very
nice of course dubrovnik is very nice i
when i talk about croatia i don't even
consider dubrovnik a part of croatia
it's like uh
it's like a place of its own it's uh you
know
uh really really different
than than uh all the the rest of croatia
uh but yeah maybe that
rock rosh gavigan intent matthew g nine
so pretty much
everyone who's been here from the
beginning has remained here
and assenio still doing uh amazing 162
followed by uh zaven chesmud
uh from armenia
with 149 points so let's let's see how
he does in this one against
mitra
ah daniel sullivan says uh
croatia was a province of rome several
roman emperors retired
there diocletian built an immense palace
in split
blind guardian thank you very much maybe
100 is too much but
uh thanks
i have the same birthday as psy wow
that's
uh that really that really means a lot
to me
but uh yeah i did not know that and uh
someone someone
someone said it already like in the
beginning of the stream
will i travel to dubai for the world
championship match uh
most probably most probably
zekitza yes or maybe yes
welcome to the team man welcome to
excellent subscribers
we accept everyone uh so you know
congratulations on your decision to join
uh we don't have much but we do have
some very nice
very nice emotes but more more are
coming
and you know the the chess is always
excellent here
will sharich play in zagreb uh i don't
think so
he was uh he was supposed to play last
time
but now for some reason again i think
that that there's some sort of a problem
with the organization or you know with
the fro
from the granchester and then with the
with the croatian chess for some reason
they he
they are not uh having him play
i i don't know why
white missed the fork with the king and
bishop
all right so kymer got all the way up
the fifth
and uh which is super impressive since
he started
very very late he played the least games
and uh he's really
really on an impressive streak but let's
see
our winner who lost yet another game now
playing against ferocious lion
who panda said it was a a farouja lion
and i didn't get the joke so that's
that's
that's pretty bad but what are you gonna
do
no i still haven't visited india
if i'm if i'm ever in swiss in
switzerland uh i have a place to say
thanks a lot man uh is there is there
any good beer
in switzerland
or or if not what is good there
how did capoblanca manage to stop uh
marshall's uh
impressive attack that he uh saved for
eight years
uh no one knows he's just capoblanca is
that good
it doesn't matter
most beautiful place i've ever been
oh i don't know uh
uh it's hard to say because uh like
only like one small place or do you mean
like a city or
a i don't know could be uh
i know i i've been to greece i i've seen
many many cool things in greece maybe
that that was uh that was very enjoyable
uh but like we have
like pleitrich kazera here in croatia
that's also you know on a good
day that's incredibly beautiful so
there's a
there's a lot you can you can
uh check out uh a senior
uh draws the game against ferocious line
all right so things are heating up at
the top
uh saving chess mode uh getting closer
and closer to a senior he's basically
there
and with 21 minutes on the clock uh
i guess it is possible to uh to uh to
catch up to him
and heisenberg in third manila mania in
fourth and
vincent uh again uh uh ha
now with a loss has paused so we'll see
if he will return
or will he sometimes you know when you
see a pause it means the
players are just like ah i'm not playing
this anymore
how's the weather in croatia right now
it's extremely hot
extremely hot but other than that very
very enjoyable
i'm the only channel who reads uh the
chat
uh with that that's why that's why i
stream i stream to you know
hang out with with the subscribers
all right uh since uh we don't have a
game here we have a game here
we got rasholov uh versus uh heisenberg
o1
all right let's see this one could also
decide uh
what what's happening at the top
marvel or dc that's uh that's a great
question yeah that is a great question
uh i'm not uh i'm not all really into
comics
uh but uh
i don't know i i myself prefer marvel
but probably
because i'm not into comics i have
friends who are into comics and they say
uh dc comics are better but marvel
movies are better
uh so you know i don't know if that's
true but it's it is what they say
what is slow mode oh slow mode is
something used to prevent
uh people spamming in the chat i think
it allows you
uh one message per maybe 15 seconds or
maybe 30 seconds
i don't know i haven't really haven't
really tested it out but
i think it could actually be 30 seconds
will they go to rapid in the world
championship uh
this time it's hard to say because i i i
think they increased it from 12 games to
16 games so if
if it's still a draw after 16 games yes
i mean of course they're gonna go to
rapid
they can't uh they can't play forever
was i ever in hungary was i ever in
hungary i think i was
once but when i was like maybe six uh we
used to
you know go from croatia to hungary to
buy uh
to buy stuff simply because it was
cheaper there
uh and then you know you you you will go
every few months
does the road a gambit yeah it's the the
greatest gambit of them all
i don't know no one played it in this
tournament so far
do i have a chess youtubers whatsapp
group no but i i have a telegram group
it's
in the description of every one of my
videos so there's a telegram
group and there's a telegram channel you
know that i use
to announce stuff uh
i actually did not announce this so
if you if you're wondering why i wasn't
there
could i set up a match between me and
magnus
perhaps but i don't see what we would
gain
from such a match
it would be fun definitely you know
uh people would laugh you know laughter
is good for people
uh i know way too little about such
things the answer should just be in the
olympics
but uh someone said and i don't remember
who but
uh could even be kasparov i don't know
uh that chess cannot be in the olympics
because to be in the olympics you have
to have
like a winter edition and the summer
edition and
in chess that is uh like impossible
like you have to have the division of
winter olympics and summer olympics and
you can't really do that with
chess
all right so what do we do all right uh
saving chess mode seven points uh short
from reaching a senior and he also just
lost the game now
oh no he he drew two games against the
senior and and semo
wow this is uh pretty crazy no one from
the top ten is allowing anyone else to
join in the top ten
is very close he came to 99 points he
was a very very
very close
all right let's see let's see one more
game and then we're gonna stick with
the with the top guys uh since we're in
the
final sorry about that final 15 minutes
of the tournament
[Music]
that does not make much sense swimming
does not have a winter variant i don't
know
i mean it's not me who said it
[Music]
uh you know like i said i i don't know
much about such
things but it sounded smart when i heard
it
where's my dog meadow is like exactly
behind me like if you really try i'm
pretty sure you can even see him
like like right here like
there yeah it's always it's always
winter in chess
am i good at cooking uh
yes i i would say yes i don't know
i like to cook stuff but
you know
am i good uh i have a very
very unique way of how i prepare things
i don't
use a lot of spices i don't uh you know
overdo anything so it's very easy to
make something that
i enjoy it's me it might be a bit
more difficult to make something someone
else would enjoy so i i don't know
if any from world top 10 wins the this
arena would you award the prize money to
him
i i don't see why not there's no
uh there's no law that uh forbids this
just because you you know you're good at
chess and then win prizes why not
will i do more uh collaborations with
other streamers
uh i might i mean like i said at the
moment i'm not really streaming all that
much but
uh yeah i mean i'm i'm definitely not
against against it
all right so let's see how are we doing
all right uh
chess move getting closer and closer
he's now up against ferocious lion
uh let's see what what happens
what's my favorite flag not in chess
i don't know maybe maybe croatia because
it has a chess board
but you know probably not
tips to grow a newly started university
chess club
well you need people definitely it's
hard to when uh when you start a chess
club at a university
at least in croatia because people join
it mostly to get out of doing other
things
so first you have to get rid of most of
them and then only you know
only allow the the good ones to stay
uh i haven't checked if we are close to
5k oh it's 48
4871 okay so if you still haven't joined
the tournament to join
so we can so we can hit 5000
participants which would be awesome
even though chances of you winning now
are very very
impossible
i you have the link in the arena it's in
the description of the of the
of the live stream
all right oh
and he manages to do it very nicely done
white runs out of time and chess mode
beats ferocious line which means that he
is
even closer to catching up to a senior
what a senior also won
uh but no no now he drew a game so now
uh
now if uh chess mode wins uh he gets the
flame and he could be
unstoppable we could be seeing uh
a new a new leader here if he wins the
next one
so let's see let's see what happens
if uh oh no i've i i've
picked the the the wrong game but okay
uh it's also one from the leader so we
can check out this one
leeches interface tricked me so out of
the
six games they played a senior won five
and the one was drawn so let's see if
manier can can take a point from a
senior
did i buy the other screen i've always
had
the other screen
is mid-rank chess more fun than top
chess uh
uh it depends on how you classify mid
rank
so is mid rank like 2600 and then top is
2750 or is mid
20 2400 or maybe you know
okay
oh i think uh i think white will not
have
a lot of problems winning this one but
we'll we'll see
he's spending a lot of time on it and if
uh
[Music]
the gentleman in second place wins
another one he gets the flame and then
maybe it doesn't matter if if assenio
wins he will not be able to keep the
lead
ah 2400 to 2600 is uh is the mid-range
okay yeah i mean those games especially
in lower time formats rapid and blitz
would be
would be super crazy but even uh the top
grand masters i mean look at what
niepo is playing look at what dubo is
playing those are i mean
those are incredible games
yelana is sending hearts uh in the chat
uh which means that uh etta is
fed and she's very nicely sleeping so
elena
has time to send hearts to all of us
thank you elena
is being good at chess linked to one's
intellectual memory or creativity
i i would imagine so yes i would imagine
so
oh what what what what white resigned
oh what was there a oh yeah oh nice
oh that that hurt that hurt which means
uh that
chess mode is very very close to to
getting it but
yeah he drew the the the last game so he
couldn't get the flame
uh that that flame the elusive leeches
flame uh he who grabs it
uh does not want to let go let it go
all right so a few more people few more
people donated for the price
so price will be increasing uh but i
will
uh i will increase it after uh after the
tournament
uh so i don't have to do all these uh
complicated calculations now
uh but yes it seems that it will be even
greater yes
all right so six more minutes uh let's
see
oh this this is uh looking to be a
pretty wild game
manier versus quick silver
yeah although it's not a bullet
tournament you know in the end everyone
berserks and then
it kind of turns into one
ah maneer moves to second with the flame
really
oh i i haven't i haven't seen it
no i i have not visited africa
unfortunately no
yeah meadow seems to be doing great on
the couch yes we had a nice
walk before the stream and we will have
to do another one
after the stream that's how metal likes
to roll
no i don't think i will be coming to the
exit festival
i i enjoyed those when i was uh younger
a bit
can you become a grandmaster if you
start playing at the age of 20
um i don't know i don't think
uh there is a known case of this
you know in in modern chess but i don't
i don't i wouldn't say it's impossible
i mean okay maybe no i i've never i
don't think i've heard of such a case
uh saurabh uh yeah i i am planning on
continuing the podcast but not
like i mentioned not in the setup that
i've done them so far
you have been shout outed
a chess literature for someone who likes
to learn while reinforcing what he has
learned in the book uh
other depends on what what do you want
to improve
uh all right let's just check how
everything is going
uh assenio still in the lead manderman
uh in second place so he overtakes
everyone with an
incredible uh streak a really incredible
one and he could even win this
if he wins the next one and oh he's
playing against heisenberg
so oh no again again leeches tricked me
again lee just
gave me a game i was i was trying to
avoid but okay
okay i see i see what's happening here
do i prefer queenside or kingside
castling uh
doesn't matter if i prefer if my
opponent castle king's side i go queen
side and
of course the other way around
okay a draw between a senior
and this uh okay so it's still it's
still on
oh lance is also here
lance is playing against the sanyo i
think uh
lance probably probably the guy who
played
the most games on leeches uh from from
title players
although he's an lm uh a leeches master
but still
no i i i do not follow cricket i've
i don't think i've ever watched a
cricket game
yeah lm it's a title you
could get at one point unleashes but
only to
i don't know i don't know who it was
given to
obviously very strong players i think
you had to be like 2400 at least on
leeches
uh and uh a contributor in some some way
i believe
not necessarily in a financial way i
mean could be
anyway you know i could be wrong
though it's just just something how i
remembered it
alright so uh uh a minute and 45 seconds
left in the tournament
with uh situation on the top of being
very
very erratic anything can happen and uh
we'll see
we'll see what happens
all right so lance might not be able to
win the tournament but he is
uh he's grabbing precious time from a
senior so we'll see if this is if this
is enough for other players to to
overtake him
or not
if points are tied does it move to a
playoff no
leeches sort sorts it out uh the the way
leeches uh uh puts it in the end that's
that's the that's the spot you have
i don't know how leeches does it uh
there are i'm pretty sure there's a
there's a uh
there's an explanation to it but i'm
pretty you know i'm sure all is fair and
in good spirit
yeah max graciously allowed magnus to
continue playing that is true yeah
yeah senior struggling 178 but he's
still
in first place uh manir mainly
only needed one more win to overtake him
and then he lost he lost to
ferocious lion so now assenio lost as
well
uh everyone is losing this is insane
i think only mandy has an opportunity if
he wins this one
[Music]
uh no i again chose the wrong one this
one does not uh help us
so yeah mandy
mandy is not playing currently yeah
that's it
he's currently he currently wasn't
playing and if he was playing and he
finished it uh
before the tournament ended then you
could still do it but
not it this way so really
this was uh incredibly intense look at
this osenyo in first place with a rating
performance of 2800
with 178 points then uh
followed by international master manila
mania uh only
two points down and he lost the last
game which would be enough to overtake
him because he had uh
he had the streak but now in second
place with 176 points
uh then in third place uh uh zaven chess
mood
uh grand masters even chess mode with
174 points so it's all
incredibly incredibly close uh
heisenberg uh with 172 points ferocious
line
uh with 126 points uh vulgar
with 117 vincent kymer who who joined
the very late
uh uh but okay uh
uh uh rashul also joined late but i
think
uh i i kind of i kind of think vincent
joined later i don't know
uh but still very very impressive 116
points
matthew g with 111 mitra ba with 109 and
aroshka evgeny with
106. and we end the tournament with
4 964 players so
uh like very very close to 5 000 players
it's too bad we didn't hit it but we
might in the next one
and i'm going to read the other 10 since
it's a pretty big tournament
uh in 11th place pigle international
master yonash
[Music]
mb i guess that's how you you could
pronounce it
in 12th place in 13 video master speed
monkey then
magenta mango in 14 quick silver 2 and
15
uh uh leeches master lands five
five five oh uh a legend unleashes uh
joined very late but uh he almost got a
perfect score only two
two losses in 16th and semo in 17th
kavit 72 in 18th
um akanda maester uh master uh sakan
toby
in 19th and bishwa hacker in 20th place
so
really really an impressive tournament
and uh like i said
uh i will be distributing the prizes uh
very soon uh i'm just i just have to add
uh because uh like i said there were
some additional contributions so
uh here you can see that it says first
place is 834
or more but there were some
contributions during the stream
uh so i have to add that so it will be
uh
a little bit more and it's distributed
evenly
between first second and third place not
evenly but in uh like in segments like
uh
you know you know what i mean uh but
yeah i will be
notifying the winners uh that they will
be
uh receiving their reward and you know
it was a it was a pretty great
tournament
uh almost 500 5 000 players uh
very happy about that so hope you guys
enjoyed that and yeah we still have to
check out that first game i mean
uh senior versus there in chestnut this
beautiful queen sacrifice here i don't
know for those of you who joined late
maybe you've missed it but here
after uh queen to be four uh bishop
captures an f3 bishop captures
now queen captures an h2 a monster
queen sacrifice and here uh of course he
resigned
uh because if you if you capture then of
course uh we just get bishop to have to
check a discovery from the rook and
that's it uh
game over okay queen will have to block
but then we pick up the queen and it's
checkmate
so really really uh amazing blow uh
or maybe better yet uh it maybe it'd be
better if i didn't show it to you so i
could do a video on it tomorrow
but maybe i'll still do it so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh sorry about no guests for this stream
i
use i prefer streaming with guests but
um
you know for this one uh it is as it is
uh but we are we're we're gonna try and
do uh
some guests for the next one uh so yeah
uh once again hope you guys enjoyed it
uh
i'll try to organize uh another one as
you guys seem to be enjoying it
uh uh a lot uh but do it at the same
time as the leeches titled the arena
here
uh we had the misfortune of uh you know
uh having the event at the exact same
time but i just uh play
i i didn't even check if there was uh if
there was the the arena happening
so yeah what are you gonna do uh but
yeah once again
thank you for for joining us in the
stream uh congratulations to the winners
once again
and i will see you soon guys